9:13 personal note when I was a little
kid my mother told me not to stare into
the Sun so once when I was six I did the
doctors didn't know if my eyes would
ever heal a B C a always BBC closing
always be closing always be closing
AI da attention interest decision action
attention do I have your attention
interest
are you interested I know you are cuz
it's [ __ ] or walk you close or you hit
the bricks decision have you made your
decision for Christ in action
ai da get out there you got the
prospects coming in you think they came
in to get out of the rain a guy don't
walk on the lot lest he wants to buy
sitting out there waiting to give you
their money are you with a ticket I
killed the last honorable man 15 years
ago since then you've seen his porch
from downstairs
mmm-hmm your mouth all glued up with
Conny juice I asked you a question I
said I seen it sir oh you got a
murderous rage in you and I like it most
life boiling up inside of you was good
the priest than me we lived by the same
principles